[Música]
llegamos a segur para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal en nada capital surcoreana
andrés sánchez sobre el brote de kobe 19
en corea del norte andrés gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 ya muy buena tarde casi noche
s para usted cuál es la situación corea
del norte en cuanto a las contagios y
fallecimientos hasta el día de hoy de
kobe 19
pues corea del norte ha reportado ocho
nuevos fallecimientos con lo cual serían
ya 50 muertes aparentemente ligadas a
lakovic 19 desde que el país detectó los
primeros casos confirmó que se trata de
kobe el pasado jueves y era es la
primera vez que el país confirma que hay
un caso de kobe en su territorio y
también ha reportado
320.000 alrededor de 320 mil nuevos
casos en casos potenciales
lo cual haría ya un total de 121
millones de contagios potenciales o
sospechosos décimos potenciales o
sospechosos porque cabe recordar que
corea del norte tiene muy poca capacidad
para realizar tests de kobe
con esos datos s 121 millones de
contagios potenciales y unas 600.000
personas aproximadamente se han
recuperado ya y en torno a unas 560 mil
estarían siendo ahora mismo
el líder norcoreano kim jong-un ha dicho
que hay que mejorar el suministro de
medicamentos a la población y ha
ordenado al ejército que participe en
estas cadenas de suministro para mejorar
el acceso a la ciudadanía a estos
fármacos la situación en general en el
corea del norte preocupa mucho primero
porque la variante que se ha detectado
es la micro novedosa llamada de micrón
silenciosa y es potencialmente muy
contagiosa y también preocupa sobre todo
porque el país no ha vacunado a nadie y
ha rechazado recibir 5 millones de
vacunas del programa kóvacs claro andrés
también el régimen norcoreano ha
rechazado a recibir las vacunas de por
ejemplo organización mundial de la salud
de china o de rusia por qué y qué tipo
de ayudas podría recibir
bueno la razón que se creó oficial por
la cual la corea del norte rechazó estas
vacunas es que no querían ningún tipo de
técnico de personal entrar al país para
asesorar la creación de estas cadenas de
frío necesarias para las vacunas hay que
recordar que condena el sur ha estado
completamente cerrada al mundo exterior
desde que comenzó la pandemia en 2020
otra razón posiblemente adicional es que
corea del norte no quiere depender de
ningún país externo en el tema de
vacunas en qué situación queda esto cuál
es la posibilidad de que corea del norte
acepte ayudas y qué tipo de ayudas pues
por poner un ejemplo corea del sur que
ha prometido ya dar todas las ayudas
necesarias
para el país vecino ha tratado de
comunicarse hoy con corea del norte y no
ha recibido por el momento respuesta
alguna por otra parte
del norte ha alabado el sistema chino de
kobe 0 y algunas fuentes informativas
han hablado de que ha habido contactos
diplomáticos con china para recibir
algún tipo de ayuda humanitaria pero
muchos expertos
subrayan en este caso que es muy poco
probable que lo que corea del norte vaya
a solicitar sean vacunas porque de nuevo
no quiere dejar entrar a nadie en el
país para asesorar esa distribución esa
correcta distribución de vacunas y otro
de los motivos sería no dejar entrar
precisamente a las personas porque el
régimen norcoreano ha reforzado mucho su
control sobre la población en ese
sentido la pandemia le ha venido muy
bien tal y como denuncian las
organizaciones de derechos humanos